so it's October which is my favorite
time of year so I am going to be telling
only stories of the McCobb the morbid
the scary and the terrible welcome to
one hundred Wonders the October edition
in 1959 a group of nine Soviet students
set out on a winter camping expedition
they were headed into the Ural Mountains
to an area known as kholat ciacco in a
local language dead mountain the group
of nine young students was experienced
hikers and they were led by a young man
named Igor
Detlef he was confident experienced he
could handle harsh weather when they
failed to show up ten days after their
expected rendezvous Soviet government
feared the worst and sent in a
helicopter looking for them and it found
some of them dead scattered away from
their tent the strangest thing was their
tent had been cut open from the inside
out this is what would become known as
the death love incident when they found
these first five students they were in
various states of disarray some were
missing shirts other people were
stripped almost entirely naked two of
them had gone off and apparently started
a campfire but there were unburned
branches next to them and their hands
had been burnt in the process there were
no other tracks to be found no people no
animals three months later they were
able to find the remaining victims one
of them was missing her tongue another
had his chest crushed two of them had
skull fractures and their bodies were
said to be a strange orange color and
their hair had gone gray the Soviet
government opened a case and closed it
just as quickly saying they had all been
killed by a compelling natural force the
files were kept secret for years making
it a subject of much risk
and conspiracy when they were finally
released some very strange things were
contained in the files one the bodies
were said to be slightly radioactive it
was also found that locals saw some
strange bright lights in the sky that
evening along with the theories are
aliens and yetis are some more sober
minded thoughts maybe they were killed
by local hunters but there was no
evidence of this kind of struggle and no
footprints of anyone except the nine
hikers one of the theories that emerged
around the question of radioactivity was
perhaps they've been accidentally dosed
in some sort of secret government test
maybe this is why the government had
closed and kept secret the files for so
long there is a new scientifically
grounded idea that may provide the
explanation but it is almost as
outlandish as aliens or Bigfoot if
you've ever gone into a building and
gotten the sense that something is
deeply wrong some scientists believe
that there is a connection between these
haunted sites and something called
infrasound sound that exists just below
the level of our hearing at this level
it starts to play Strange tricks on the
human mind in an experiment with
hundreds of people 22% of them when
exposed to infrasound had experiences of
extreme fear terror sorrow general
nausea and anxiousness overwhelmed then
an infrasound can be produced both
artificially and in nature on that night
high winds may have created an
infrasonic Oh chamber and it may have
been that Igor Detlef was convinced that
what he was hearing was an avalanche
come aboard
they all went scattering into the night
in sub-zero temperatures some of them it
seems maybe fell down a mountainside the
four that were found later and said to
be orange and gray-haired
had undergone a certain amount of
so mummification they had just been
exposed to the elements for too long
the missing tongue that's a raven or
another forest creature getting a snack
the crust chest may have just been the
pressure of snowpack slowly compressing
this body over months and months so well
we may never know the real answer to
this mystery the best theory out there
that the Ural Mountains themselves the
harsh environment is what killed them
but it was the wind itself that drove
them to madness watch more videos here
and subscribe here
so well this is the best explanation out
there it doesn't answer every question
the bright lights seen that night could
be a number of things the area was in
line with the buccaneer cosmodrome so it
might have just been normal Soviet
launches and the radioactivity has
always been a very puzzling piece of
this the explanation is that their
candles contained thorium and that would
have given them all a little bit of a
radioactive tinge one of the group when
he fled the tent fled without his
clothes but took his camera and on the
roll is one final blurry photograph what
he was trying to take a picture of will
remain a mystery